alors est-ce qu'on vous avait prévenu
que c'était la semaine de la galoche non
c'était la semaine
artero luiz est si prompt à dire là
dessus mais pas obligé non non c'était
la semaine de la gauche pour cyril
hanouna chepchirchir égal au chic
mathieu doit embaucher embrassé comme ça
on va le voir tout de suite on va tous
vous voir vous inquiétez pas encore en
twitter vous avez embrassé deux sex
symbol de la télé cyril féraud et
magloire non-jeu présence et par région
plus il se rappelait plus vraiment à
cécile féroé celui dont vous avez
réalisé le rêve au bout de quatre ans
matthieu delormeau et il n'est pas
vraiment moi c'est on va le voir vous
agacer le borgne autant assumer quand
même me suis rendu compte en fait cyril
je me rends compte que tpm pc d une
émission où vous parliez médias et où
vous galochier les invités ah oui oui
regardez j'ai la preuve
tabata aucun problème embrasser syrie il
est prêt
et quand même du mal à embrasser le
justin bieber des femmes de plus de 90
ans en disant vous allez galocher pas
mal de mal connue quand même
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté
[Musique]
dix ans vous avez embrassé tous les
hommes célèbres du paf tout sauf le
leader tnt du vendredi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et mathieu dormant vais rater son coup
il ya quelques semaines mais son rêve
s'est réalisé lundi ça m'a rappelé une
scène très connue d'un film souvenez
vous allez de bizi embrassez vous allez
faites le baiser le baiser le masi le
baiser les baisers cvo wendel le maire
[Applaudissements]
maltais bob un amour éternel 110 morts
je tiens à préciser que c'est un
accident ne se reproduira plus de
quillan et au dessert il a les yeux
voilà j'ai été obligé parce que voilà et
je leur avais mis du chocolat je me suis
dit voilà il faut donner
voilà pour recevoir à et voilà qu'est ce
qui se passe
non rien et comme vous embrasser que les
mecs depuis dix ans vous êtes à chaque
fois obligé où vous avez un truc à lui
dire que des meilleurs c'est pas que
vous verrez quand vous aurez votre show
à la grecque il falloir il faut savoir
mouiller la chemise
voilà je voulais qu à moi j'avais les
lèvres humide de jeu sont pas là pardon
ne s'était pas ce n'était pas juste un
baiser comme ça bah non mais je vous le
disais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
selon public maintenant vous êtes gentil
qu'on a deviné ya aucun public derrière
celle au ce sera la dernière fois que
j'en vois serait matthieu delormeau que
ce soit à l'antenne ou à ramper voilà
c'est terminé en 2019 les noms de la vie
entière au boulot di donc maintenant on
va jouer dit la vie entière voilà
vraiment où il avait eu aucun plaisir
c'est qu'on n'annonce rien habana aucun
n'a rien à l'aube à frémissement
qu'est-ce-qui non non non qu'est-ce qui
est dans son coin c'est une question ou
d'hommes alors qu'un aucun frémissement
qu'on appelle à toutes ces personnes je
n'embrasse et des hommes
j'aime beaucoup la moitié ferme et la
lèvre qui s'est légèrement gonflé un
petit peu qu'ils allaient voter oui bon
on voit que les vacances à sion a des
bons souvenirs
on voit les vacances approchent parce
que cyril vous voulez c'est de plus en
plus marcher sur les pieds ah oui j'ai
remarqué depuis quelques jours vous êtes
fait enchaîner par les chroniqueurs
alors on va voir qu'on fait un gros
travail de maîtrise de vous-même vous
n'avez qu'une seule vraie envie en fait
c'est de défoncer la rase de tout le
monde sait mais vous restez zen devrez
découvrir la bad max pons réponse 6,6
réponse lice brabham ici combien y'a 2 0
/ voit la fiche de paye jours
deux fois par jour quelle est la
question des gangs et en deux fois par
jour vous appelez votre banquier
si vous avez plus à la paire vous voulez
quoi voilà qui fait un truc moi je
braque la bibliothèque nationale
ah ouais pas mal mes manuscrits
originaux comme cyril
si plus rien à perdre j'ai un casse
d'une banque moi comme bernard un casse
mais votre parking de voitures un gps un
gps oui quel accessoire vous est
nécessaire pour trouver une librairie
[Applaudissements]
la maîtrise de soi quoi sauver quelques
amis franchement t'as vu comme une tv
comme une attaque tout le temps il n'y a
pas de respect merci calme et l'ordre et
tu trouves aussi merci camille persie
mais maintenant je vais compter sur toi
racheter castaldi est toujours gentil
avec moi toujours apparents les rp à
part en dehors du plateau où il essaie
toujours de m'attaquer sera mieux
d'ailleurs valu à là ça m'arrange que je
suis dans le bon axe est prévue vers
sabha la séquence que hier on avait un
petite échauffourée avec castaldi qu'a
voulu m'attaquer encore un an l'homme
est arrêté si c'est vrai c'est pas été
pas vrai reste à 1 m on ne donne pas
d'ordre à moi monsieur s'il vous plaît
bon bah voilà battait pas rester un mois
je l'adoré oui alors on vient de voir
vous acceptez les vannes sur vous car
vous avez un contrôle total samedi
prochain thibout trade d'abrutis vous ne
connaissez pas vous regarder dans les
yeux en allait ainsi vous traite de
connard vous ne connaissez pas vous
regarder dans les yeux vous en aller un
type vous dit que vous avez même humour
que bruno guillon là ça fait plus mal
j'ai compris votre tête qui veut dire ah
ça c'est un peu fort de café quand même
c'est un nouveau zoom baba
[Musique]
bah
c'est que bruno guillon qui à la radio
est assez second degré assez drôle est
tous un peu d'humour comme voix dont
celle ci voulait alors que c'est lui qui
mène en fait à quoi vous avez bien vous
fait ça j'ai bien bouffer ou deux je dis
rien je dis bien je ferme ma gueule
voilà alors saxon bonjour c'est le
chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va revenir dessus c'est un des plus
beaux shows pas j'ai gardé le goût de
chocolat grimont c'était magnifique on
n'a pas eu une ére peuvent lui dire en
attendant franchement si j'étais laurent
weil le spécialiste cinéma de canal+
je me ferais du souci pour ma place
parce que après la le monde de la dark
avec tpm paix le monde sociétale à
valence est en poste cyril hanouna
d'essayer s'attaquer au monde du cinoche
ouais le grand écran vous avez
interviewé ce work et kevin rare
équivalent américaine charlie et lulu
dans les plus grandes stars mondiales je
veux c'est très bien mais je
souhaiterais mais je les adore en plus
le feeling est bien passé entre vous
pourtant pour se faire comprendre
c'était pas facile votre truc
j'ai compris c'est de parler français
avec l'accent américain en espérant ou
qui vous comprennent ont répété
plusieurs fois la même chose en espérant
qui vous comprennent chante avec des
fonciers je sais voilà le retour du
journal de cinéma sur ma dernière ce
soir
[Musique]
me de roc mwami ce mot je mouille le mec
moral et l'espionné parler l'espionner
j'aime beaucoup c'est pourquoi et qu'on
perd ensuite pour faire style que vous
comprenez tous ces deux techniques la
première c'est la technique du ok ok ok
ok ok et choqué ah ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
quand on vous pose une question à
laquelle vous n'avez rien compris pour
vous c'est le drame
à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les deux les deux ont été exceptionnels
il embrasse très fort et au team
cartonne 12mji allez le voir très très
bon film c'est très bon ouais alors
est-ce qu'on revient sur le joaillier
tout de suite et on revient alors on
revient sur le chocolat guêtres dans un
instant son instance est l un des plus
beaux chocolat gaza doit vraiment des
années les chéris du mois alors série
lundi pendant toute l'émission vous
avait promis qu'il n'y aurait pas de
chocolat gates ben franchement je vois
pourquoi les chroniqueurs douté parce
que quand vous dites qu'il n'aura pas de
chocolat gates qu'il n'y aura pas de
chocolat gagnant
alors c'est vrai que j'avais oublié
cyril aussi vous était surnommé l'animal
est aussi pipeau man il a un truc à nous
dire dans un instant en toi tu rappes
jeudi tout le monde croit c'est du
chocolat c'est pas du chocolat c'est une
vraie un vrai bail après ce galop déjà
parti de toutes les façons ça causerait
pas avec michel blanc gobain comme
d'habitude quand cyril promet quelque
chose il tient parole bien entendu il
n'y aura pas de feu d'artifice de
chocolat les chauffeurs ces récits qui
dès qu'ils haïssaient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il demande aussi de t'acheter une
teinturerie
alors ce soir n'aura pas de chocolat
c'est antoine de caunes qui m'avait
demandé parce que tout soit on le
retrouvera dans les olympiens ward et
antoine m'a dit je peux faire tout ce qu
la cire il voit là et j'ai voulu faire
plaisir à mon ami antoine introduisez
mois voilà c'est tout bas oui ils vont
faire plaisir
bah oui il va il fait plaisir aux potes
comme je vois la cemac à savoir ce que
monsieur michel rocard pense que ce
chocolat gates
alors là c'est une très faible
[Applaudissements]
m
allez tout de suite une nouveauté fm
rose laurens après kg mois la régie
n'était pas meilleur quand elle est en
grève
michel debré pour cyber la moitié tu
connais bien sûr je connais bien n'at on
s'appelle de temps en temps c'est vrai
bien sûr il conseille tous les
présidents tous les tous les insulaires
et il aime les animaux qui l'a mise à
niveau quoi nous aussi toi tu as changé
fouet
tu peux toujours te mettre en exergue à
cette forme étoiles alors elle parle
mais là c'est doux c'est kivu et qui
nous bat tout le monde c'est vrai oui
bien sûr merci en tout cas très beau
mais très bonnes interventions
alors vous l'économie shell vous
répondre oui s'il vous plaît michel à
on ne peut me répondre à cette question
le chocolat gates qu'en penses tu pas
grand chose voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
échappé belle il y aura peut-être un qui
va débarquer je vous dit il n'y aura
plus de chocolat gates jusqu'à janvier
méfiez-vous le 6 oui c'est tout et vous
dis comme ça vous oublierez pas
on a eu des cadeaux de noël voir là-bas
noël de jeudi prochain
ah oui direct il vous verrez ce soir
j'ai dessiné un dérivé du tabac c'est le
petit un baba alors pourquoi le petit
arabe art qu'est ce que c'est que le
tabac alors que le plus tacler ses
collègues sur le plateau et là j'ai créé
le petit temps là bas pourquoi parce que
c'est entièrement consacré à fabien
lecoeuvre
fabien qui n'est pas avec nous ce soir
malheureusement parce qu'ils tournent un
film d'action qui s'appelle regarder
fast and furious kids et ne croyez pas
si bien dire
savait que fabien dans se régaler il va
peut-être moins être avec nous c'est non
à part certainement tourné que les kits
united pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc ce soir je vais récompenser celui
qui dit bonjour c'est vrai c'est
manipule alors ce soir fut récompensé
celui ou celle qui a le plus tacler
l'encyclopédie des gens décédés musique
de suspense sert il
donc c'est celui qui a le plus tacler
fabien le club fabien lecoeuvre dont
clients vers des pailles qu'une musique
du spectacle aux excès mois la famille
chaque été au goût si oui mais bon
effectivement le gagnant et sait rien
d'eux un peu glissé pas t'en fout d'eux
quand on vous donne des radins cadeau et
vous allez souvent en mer c'est vrai
c'est une belle phrase olivier fabre
accusant this un peu pourquoi vous êtes
très beau mais regarder pourquoi vous
avez gagné le trophée mais j'adore
arbache adore ton anniversaire
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
vous regardez vous savez ce qu'il a fait
tout pour énerver nom kasseem maximov
grève de la croissance au début de ma
carrière j'avais j'avais des lunettes en
titane très légère et souvent prenez
pour delarue tête de la rue petit et de
l'impasse quoi il fait du caroupaye
attendu les millions de personnes qui
sont de ma taille ou moins en si mineur
en france devant surfer sur la mode fort
boyard en créant la nouvelle émission à
bologne arland et des nouveaux
personnages ya passe nulle part c'est à
double passe mais c'est que des nains
double langage il n'y a pas ce lecoeuvre
les chroniqueurs sont les n'ont pas
bougé maxime est là ouais mais bon nous
on est là et bien là
baba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cela je faisais famille le premier
rôle
[Applaudissements]